Factoriza 4x a la cuarta "y" menos 8x al cubo y menos 2x cuadrada,
muy bien. Entonces tenemos que encontrar el máximo comun factor
o bien, el máximo factor común de estos tres monomios. Así que déjame reescribir la expresión con un poco más de colores
4x a la cuarta "y" menos 8x al cubo y menos 2x cuadrada, 2x cuadrada.
Y vamos a encontrar el máximo factor
común, ahora lo que hacíamos antes era partir cada uno de los monomios en sus partes más simples,
que tenía que ver con una factorización
en primos pero, creo que ya tenemos algo de práctica en eso, así que vamos a intentar hacerlo
mentalmente, vamos a empezar con la parte numérica.
¿Cuál es el máximo número que divide a los tres monomios?
Pues es 2 verdad 2 divide a 4, 2 divide a 8 y 2 divide a 2, y ya no hay ningún otro número más
grande que funcione justo por que tenemos este 2. Entonces la parte numérica del máximo factor común va a ser 2.
¿Ok? Ahora vamos a la parte con "x", aquí tenemos una "x" a la cuarta, una "x" al cubo y un "x" al cuadrado
entonces la máxima potencia de "x" que divide a los 3 monomios,
es "x" al cuadrado, 2x al cuadrado y finalmente ¿qué sucede con "y"?
bueno pues aquí tenemos "y" y aquí tenemos "y"
estos dos términos tienen "y" pero éste no, como éste no tiene el "y",
el máximo factor común no puede tener "y"
¿Vale? Entonces el máximo factor común es igual a 2x al cuadrado
¿Ok? Entonces ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es pensar a cada uno de estos términos
como 2x al cuadrado por algo más,
y para ver qué es ese algo más, lo voy a hacer de la siguiente manera.
Mira, voy a reescribir este término 4x a la cuarta "y" así
como 2x al cuadrado por 4x a la cuarta "y"
dividido entre 2x al cuadrado, éste con éste se hace un 1 y entonces esta expresión es la misma que ésta
¿Vale?
¿Ok?
Repitiendo lo mismo con estos de acá, tenemos -2x al cuadrado por 8x al cubo
"y" dividido entre 2x al cuadrado, éste con éste se cancelan, menos
menos y éste último se va a ver un poco chistoso, mira es 2x al cuadrado por 2x al cuadrado,
2x al cuadrado dividido entre 2x al cuadrado incluso hasta se ve un poco bobo ¿Verdad?.
Pero bueno ahorita vas a saber porqué estoy haciendo esto. Lo que sigue ahora es, ahora sí ya podemos
factorizar este 2x al cuadrado o bien desdistribuirlo por así decirlo. Entonces vamos a
desdistribuirlo. Aquí nos quedaría 2x al cuadrado multiplicado por
y tenemos que simplificar
cada una de estas expresiones. La rosa, la naranja y la azul, la azul esta re fácil ¿Verdad?
Esto de aquí simplemente es un 1,
entonces ahorita lo ponemos pero, vamos vamos con la rosa.
Aquí nos quedaría qué cosa, sería 4 entre 2 es 2, luego "x" a la cuarta entre "x" es "x" al cuadrado,
entre "x" cuadrada ¿Verdad? Es "x" al cuadrado, luego está "y" no se divide con nada,
entonces simplemente nos queda la "y"
muy bien, esa es la parte rosa.
Menos esta parte naranja 8 entre 2 es 4x al cubo, entre "x" al cuadrado es "x"
y "y" otra vez no se divide con nada, nos queda "y" y tenemos que restar lo que queda de
simplificación que ya dijimos que era un 1.
¿Vale? Entonces aquí tenemos la factorización de la expresión que nos dan aquí arriba, y parece ser que lo hice un poco
latoso y más o menos largo pero, justo te quería explicar de dónde salen las ideas para factorizar esto poco a poco ¿Vale?
En realidad después cuando agaremos un poco más de práctica,
podemos hacer la factorización un poco más a simple vista,
o sea ya que agarras práctica puedes decir, a ver vamos a factorizar esto,
¿cómo le hacemos para factorizar?
pues tenemos que poner, tenemos que poner el número más grande
entonces el número más grande que divide es 2.
Luego en la máxima potencia de "x" que divide es "x" al cuadrado y la máxima potencia de "y"
pues éste no tiene, entonces no va a ninguna ¿Va? Entonces dirías, ah éste es el,
esto es lo que va afuera y así inmediatamente vas a
distribuirlo y para distribuirlo es bueno ¿Cuánto es 4x a la cuarta "y" entre 2x cuadrada?
Pues nos quedaría
4 entre 2 es 2, "x" a la cuarta entre "x" cuadrada es "x" cuadrada,
"x" cuadrada y aquí nos quedaría "y" luego menos
menos 8x al cubo "y" entre 2x al cuadrado, 8 entre 2 es 4
"x" al cubo entre "x" al cuadrado es "x" y la "y" queda.
Muy bien y finalmente 2x al cuadrado entre 2x al cuadrado es -1 ¿Va?
Entonces esto ya parece un poco mágico es una forma bastante más
rápida pero, para que veas que no es magia por eso pasé por todos estos pasos
y observa si nos dio lo mismo
y bueno, también si realizas la multiplicación y vuelves a distribuir este 2x al cuadrado
puedes ver que en efecto estas dos expresiones son iguales.